call me smush the other night you  haven't seen it yet yeah it was  fantastic coming yeah it's coming yeah  we heard you this  we heard you talked about all about  Mariah and Brian and the gang looking to  you  uh-huh he's got to wait for he's coming  on Showtime he's gonna be hilarious is  my third one  yeah I don't want to give anything away  they're not gonna have the same of that  but we talk about every day  [Music]  what about holiday plans always you're  fast approaching with the kids well  how's it gonna work that out  Oh fun all love you know it yeah yeah  yeah you guys are good about it that's  the holidays mainly are for kids anyway  anything about it and then once you go  from kids it's all about family and love  and that's what we're all trying to  spray  [Music]  you